hello my name is Marco tempest I'm a
cyber illusionist I was invited to Davos
to show how the art of evolution has
advanced in the digital age in bandon
various panels and sanchize a chance to
delve into my personal creative journey
combining digital technology in the art
of magic the question of wine and
technological age magic still has the
capacity to fool us and how my approach
to creating illusions can be used in
many other fields of endeavor I would
like to answer Brian's question what
keeps you motivated well well magic may
be entertainment but society needs it
what kind of place will be live in
without entertainment magic involves a
lot of creativity and working with other
creative people I also believe that
entertainment is a kind of therapy
taking people out of their lives and
responsibility for a brief moment in
some cases providing lasting hope or
even vision for the future our dreams
are built on inspiration from great
performers movies art and literature and
if someone comes to you in 10 years time
and says hey you will seeing you that
made me go out and create something of
my own well that's a job well done I
think that's what motivates creative
people smiles after all are contagious
and there is nothing more rewarding than
to put smiles on the faces of the
theater full of people so Thank You Ryan